on
bonsoir l'information nous est parvenue
il ya quelques minutes un boeing 737
s'est écrasé aujourd'hui près de
l'aéroport de colorado springs aux états
unis les 25 personnes qui étaient à bord
ont été tués
il s'agit d'un appareil de united
airlines qui devait relier d'anvers à
colorado springs
on ignore encore l'origine de la
catastrophe émotion après l'annoncé de
la mort de serge gainsbourg hier soir
gainsbarre le provocateur gainsbourg
l'artiste qui rêvait d'être peintre
portrait d'un homme que l'on aimé ou que
l'on détestait dominique penser bah j'ai
tout perdu et puis les études j'ai eu
tout et voilà c'est à l'homme est grande
je vous j'en ai bavé pas vous cet homme
à la tête de chou commis c'était des pas
lui-même en ancien élève surdoué de
l'école des beaux-arts
c'était une figure emblématique de la
chanson française mais saura-t-on jamais
qu'il était vraiment ce fils d'émigrés
russes qui pouvait se livrer jusqu'à la
pudeur et je suis entré ces gens et
fondre en larmes comme un gosse devant
les enfants et en même temps cultiver
son image du roi de la provoc et comme
mieux encore épaissir le mystère le
terrain lui et de charlotte avait
coutume de dire gainsbourg ce barcamp
gainsbarre sebourg aimer ou détester
gainsbourg gainsbarre n'aura en tout cas
jamais suscité l'indifférence et nul ne
lui contestera qui sera pris comme
personne pour accompagner les modes
sinon les devancer jasir up with pop
reggae funky en 30 ans de carrière il se
sera passé avec tout le génie fou lancé
à tous les genres de musique sans jamais
abandonner ses propres sonorités car ce
musicien poète avait aussi du caractère
il y avait une trilogie dans ma vie
c'était le tabac l'alcool les femmes je
pars et et je crains rien après avoir
être arrêté je suis venu te dire que je
étonnant
oui inchangé
comme dit si bien de rennes
je suis venu te dire jean christophe
averty vous connaissiez gainsbourg
depuis plus de 40 ans qu'elle qui va
rester le gainsbourg je crois qu'ils
restent tous tant qu'il y aura des gens
pour rôle apprécié sa musique et
défendre l'homme qui se voulait
récupérables vous avez travaillé avec
lui quelqu'un ce qu'est ce que vous
retenez de lui qu'est ce qui vous a
frappé celle d'aujourd'hui l'homme de
je suis un homme extrêmement courtois
extrêmement pudique extrêmement timide
lestement craintif extrêmement peu sûr
de lui et ont une peur tragique qu'on le
récupère à il avait la peur on essaie de
porc panique d'être avalé par ses idées
qu'ils vont vous me fait réellement vrai
fait réaliste qu'il était ou en vrai
dada east side kick ass et les assiettes
la génération de l'extrême après-guerre
fait qu'il y avait 20 ans 48 ce fut mon
cas ce fut le sien ne mettez plus que ce
qu'ils avaient combattu pour des
libertés la permission de l'amour et les
permissions de l'humour on leur conteste
le droit de l'exercer
les gaz mort fait partie de cette
génération dont ferrer était au fis un
des héros la compagne de gainsbourg
bambou qui a alerté les pompiers hier
soir ils ont découvert son corps sans
vie dans son hôtel particulier rue de
verneuil
ils étaient des centaines aujourd'hui à
se recueillir dans le quartier bertrand
edel edouard de basic hommage ému et
silencieux de plusieurs centaines de
parisiens cet après midi devant le
domicile de serge gainsbourg dans le 7e
arrondissement
dès l'annoncé de la disparition de
l'artiste les admirateurs de gainsbarre
se sont massés derrière les barrières de
police dressés de part et d'autre de la
rue de verneuil
certains sont restés là toute la nuit
d'autres arrivées dans la journée
cachent leur tristesse derrière des
lunettes noires
je n'y crois pas mes yeux j'y crois pas
encore je vais passer par bus team que
ce soit gaz bar et disparaître
il est jeune 15 bat c
pour nous c'est un gars super c'est le
mec comme ça pour moi c'est une grande
porte sur watch je le dis franchement
j'adorais j'entends de st
comme une grande perte parce que c'est
un
très ancienne voie est extraordinaire
il laisse une oeuvre nouvelle histoire
derrière
moi ce qui m'a toujours surpris c'était
7 le des petits trous des p'tits trous
rien que des petits trous parce que
c'était ça et puis le grand nouméa c'est
pas vrai il est pas dans il sera jamais
dans le grand tout il sera toujours là
jean christophe averty vous avez écouté
les réactions dans la rue gainsbourg
était un homme qu'on ne pouvait qu aimer
ou détester il pouvait pas laisser
indifférent
et je pense que personnelle d'exister
seuls les combles détesté il y faisait
mais quand démobilisé comme bien jour se
définit parfaitement c'est comme des
gens qu'ils aiment ou n'aiment pas le
jazz ce qui nous importe qu'un jour je
le mette dans un panier à ordures voilà
bien zemmour était la pureté même c'est
un homme sans comptes qui n'a fait
aucune concession
sinon qu'elle lui même et ils sont vous
l'a énormément de participer de ce monde
qu'il n'aimait guère somme toute
et quand j'ai travaillé avec lui j'ai
fait j'ai tourné gras pour lui et avec
lui jean birkin made in his own j'ai
fait mes meilleurs souvenirs de tournage
ça s'est passé merveilleusement bien ils
me disaient de temps en temps ils ont du
temps vers le voir ici c'est parce que
il avait envie de faire de l'image et du
filet mais il en a fait peu après
d'ailleurs et ça l'amusait brusquement
que de voir d une chute de ses chances
de cette chanson cette mélopée que
l'idée l'essonne ont peuvent étirer
autre chose qu'un vif que vient fillon
noir ils étaient étonnés est toujours
régi effet les jeunes puceaux platero
pour qui la juge pour qu'il aille faire
l'artiste
merci jean christophe averty fr3 rend
hommage ce soir à serge gainsbourg en
rediffusant le divan d'henri chapier qui
lui était consacré l'après guerre du
golfe le cessez le feu n'est pas encore
signé mais l'accord est total entre les
commandants alliés et les commandants
irakiens
ils se sont rencontrés pour la première
fois ce matin le point sur cette réunion
avec nos envoyés spéciaux
pierre babey et albert ripamonti tout
simples tentes vertes plantes et aux
alentours de safwan au sud de l'irak
dans une zone contrôlée par les troupes
alliées autour de la table du cessez le
feu le général schwarzkopf le patron du
desert storm et le prince général khalid
ben soltane le commandant du théâtre
d'opérations en face d'eux les irakiens
deux officiers dont le numéro trois du
ministère de la défense et un diplomate
des affaires étrangères irakienne
premier geste symbolique du général
schwarzkopf
faire dégager les soldats alliés qui
entoure les irakiens afin dira-t-il de
ne pas humilier ses officiers quelques
heures de discussions suffiront à
entériner la fin des combats et à
préciser les conditions d'application du
cessez le feu
première de ces conditions les
prisonniers de guerre doivent être
libérés immédiatement
bagdad détient entre 13 et 20 soldats de
la coalition
les alliés ont capturé entre 80 et 100
75 mille irakien
mesure d'élargissement identique
concernant les civils comme et y amener
un otage par les soldats de saddam
hussein il y en aurait plusieurs
milliers peut-être même jusqu'à 33 mille
autres exigences des alliés la
délégation irakienne s'engage à fournir
toutes les informations permettant de
localiser les dépôts d'armes chimiques
et biologiques ainsi que les champs de
mines au koweït et dans les eaux
internationales
les irakiens ayant accepté toutes ces
conditions les hostilités sont suspendus
définitivement mais les troupes
coalisées n'évacuerons le territoire
irakien qu'après la signature du cessez
le feu
pierre babey vous êtes en direct de ryad
nous venons de voir les différentes
conditions donc sur ce cessez-le-feu
encore beaucoup d'incertitudes sur le
calendrier calendrier de la libération
des prisonniers notamment
oui vous avez raison de parler d'
incertitudes il y à des incertitudes
mineure il ya une incertitude majeure
incertitudes mineurs c'est la date et le
lieu de la signature officielle du
cessez le feu
on attend que l'irak souscrivent à la
résolution 686 des nations unies pour
savoir si cette signature aura lieu
entre militaires c'est à dire pas très
loin d'ici ou entre politique et
diplomate c'est à dire au sein même du
conseil de sécurité des nations unies
mais l'incertitude majeure c'est la
situation politique et la survie du
régime de saddam hussein on a parlé de
mouvements troupe de du front de la
turquie qui faisait mouvement sur la
capitale bagdad
on ne sait pas si ces mouvements ont été
commandés par saddam hussein par
ailleurs vous le dirai plus tard dans le
journal mais il y à des mouvements de
résistance qui commencent à s'organiser
dans le sud à bassora et à naciria et
enfin on ne sait toujours pas si saddam
hussein va pouvoir rétablir la vie
civile et les conditions de survie de sa
population notamment dans la capitale
voilà donc pour les incertitudes qui
planent encore ici à la suite de cette
rencontre d'aujourd'hui
merci beaucoup pierre michel babin
pardon michel jobert vous fait le grand
témoin de ce journal le général
schwarzkopf aujourd'hui s'est montrée
sus soucieux de ne pas humilier les
irakiens est-ce que vous pensez que ce
conflit va justement provoqué d'une
humiliation profond au sein de la
population irakienne refasse et c'est
déjà fait alors maintenant on peut en
effet avoir assez de essayer d'avoir du
tact je vais vous dire ce qu'ils y
adhèrent l'air tout cela à mon avis
c'est que ces résolutions des nations
unies qui sont derrière le projet
armistice aucun autre régime irakien ne
peut les accepter que le régime de
saddam hussein et par conséquent il y à
une sorte de connivence qui n'est pas
voulue entre
saddam hussein et les américains
aujourd'hui pour qu'il y ait un régime
irakien qu'ils puissent accepter ces
conditions qu'ils sont si le 18 mai
l'écouté elles sont la reconstruction
par l'irak du koweit est une fille et
des désirs réalité de ce genre de
disposition aucun état irakien
n'acceptera ceci car il ne pourra pas le
faire
donc quand on fait des traités en
général on essaie de mettre des clauses
qui sont réalisables et il n'y a que
saddam hussein qui puisse accepter
l'irréalisable nous ne croyez pas la
victoire du droit international à la
victoire de l'onu ce n'est plus le
machin dont parle et je me réjouis je
suis un peu vieux j'ai vu beaucoup de
choses entendu beaucoup de discours
vous avez très bien que le droit
international a servi d'appuyer habillé
pauvrement une opération qui d'une
opération d'impérialisme occidentales on
le sait en réponse en effet à
l'occupation dramatique d'un état libre
le koweit par son voisin l'irak
alors cessons de nous raconter des
petites histoires car dans un instant je
le suppose nous parleront peut-être des
républiques baltes et de leur liberté et
du droit international mais si vous
voulez qu'on reste dans la zone
je vais vous énumérer tous les endroits
où le droit international depuis 40 ans
saigne abondamment
au point que les victimes sont saignés à
blanc nous y reviendrons dans un instant
tout d'abord de nouvelles images de
saddam hussein elles viennent de nous
parvenir
saddam hussein qui était singulièrement
absent au cours de ces derniers des
derniers jours par dont le numéro un
irakien est entouré d'une partie de son
état-major des discussions nous dit la
télévision irakienne autour de la remise
en état des médias irakiens qui avaient
été endommagées durant les bombardements
depuis 10 ans on parle de nombreuses
manifestations justement anti saddam
hussein dans plusieurs villes du sud de
l'irak
l'opposition chiite affirme ce soir
contre les bassorah et plusieurs
agglomérations
impossible pour les journalistes de se
rendre dans la ville de bassorah les
informations reposent sur des
témoignages de personnes qui ont fui
l'irak
dernière information avec hanna mina par
téléphone du koweït city m'a confié le
consul du coup étant ses films à
versailles d'un match qui était aussi
prisonnier hier soir l'épisode heures
ils apprenaient leur leader l'imam
vaillamment sa m1 facteur est un
religieux irakiens opposants connus sont
amusés à téhéran les a jugés au plus le
maire de bassorah ce tout nouveau
responsable passé ont été tuées et l'ont
détruit les bâtiments administratifs
mais ajoutera c'est le matin ce matin à
7 heures de la garde présidentielle
iranienne était à la frontière du coup
et ont attaqué la ville toujours comment
composer la révolution islamique et ses
800 explique le conseil qui rencontre
emma travail d'amateur à 38 me mettre
dans la voiture qui nous ramener vers
korité a affirmé avant un message
révolution islamique pour les alliés un
message d'appel à l'aide
les insurgés de bassorah souhaite que
les années interdisent aux troupes
d'élite envoyé des renforts sur l'île et
empêcher l'intervention des hélicoptères
de l'armée irakienne
michel joubert et saddam hussein encore
un avenir en irak
je vais vous dire les chefs d'état ne
gagneront pas le paradis en condamnant
les autres à l'enfer c'est ce que je
vous disais il y a un instant alors il y
a plusieurs solutions maintenant en
effet saddam hussein et commode pour
accepter l'inacceptable
et puis il ya l'armée et puis il ya là
ça sera pas la victoire la révolution
islamique
c'est à dire la république serbe du
système iranien installé alors en irak
voilà des perspectives qui ne sont ni
les unit des autres très brillante c'est
pas le système démocratique tel que nous
connaissons en occident qui va
s'installer après dab ou si on le croit
aussi les chefs d'état occidentaux le
croire je crains qu'il ne soit trop naïf
vous avez rencontré saddam hussein dont
82 je crois qu est-ce que vous
retenu du personnage c était dans une
mauvaise passe à ce moment là ils
cherchaient désespérément
non je n'en veux pas te dis je des
rencontres et quand il était encore dans
son ses difficultés avec l'iran et y
chercher et des médiateurs donc lui de
tuer quelqu'un qui désespérément essayé
de faire prendre en compte son dossier y
compris militaires par d'autres
puissances et ils cherchaient mais ne
trouvait pas de porte de sortie
le 30e anniversaire de l'accession
d'hassan ii au trône du maroc pas d'
amnistie générale annoncée en faveur des
détenus politiques
en revanche en cours de son discours
officiel le roi hassan ii a lancé qu'il
se préoccupait des droits de l'homme
cette semaine grâce royale je vous le
rappelle pour 2270 un détenu dont la
famille du général a requis ces mesures
d' amnistie annoncé par hassan ii à
votre avis c'est un tournant dans le
régime marocain
écoutez je suis plus que d'autres
attentif à ce qui se passe là bas
le tournant il s'est produit
curieusement au mois de mai l'an dernier
où le roi fait un discours qui était un
véritable tournant les médias n'en ont
pas beaucoup tenu compte je dirais que
lui même n'en a
sur le moment pas tenu compte mais il
est en train d'appliquer ce qu'il avait
annoncé
et notamment mes tard mon avis une prise
en compte réelle dans le fonctionnement
de son régime des droits élémentaires de
la personne humaine alors je vous dirais
il y a eu une maturation beaucoup trop
tardive la création de ce conseil
consultatif qui était le pure forme au
début et qui curieusement aujourd'hui
comment ça fonctionne et à faire des
propositions en quelque sorte aoc
défendre les sujets pour lesquels il a
été nommé hassan ii s'était rangée on se
le rappelle aux du côté des forces
alliées durant la guerre du golfe est ce
que vous pensez que cette position va
lui poser des problèmes au sein de
de son pays tous les chefs d'état qui
ont été arabes qui ont été dans cette
coalition vont d'une manière ou d'une
autre avoir des problèmes considérables
alors ça dépendra de leur talent et puis
de deux circonstances de se tirer assez
bien de une difficulté qui est une
difficulté montante sorte un droit aussi
bien l'égypte que que le maroc
il peut-être que d'autres et le sénégal
la lettonie et l'estonie ont voté
aujourd'hui un référendum sur
l'indépendance des deux républiques
baltes
un nouveau défi pour michael gorbatchev
le mois dernier on s'en souvient les
lituaniens s'étaient déjà prononcés
massivement pour le retrait de l'union
soviétique filippis terre la barricade
est toujours devant le parlement de riga
témoignages détention du mois de janvier
mais c'est dans le calme que lettons et
estoniens vote depuis ce matin première
victoire des indépendantistes la forte
participation au moins 70% déjà avant
les deux républiques baltes à 15h
référendum pour l'estonie sondages
d'opinion pour la lettonie
l'enjeu de ces scrutins est clair les
populations de ces durées publiques sont
elles favorables
oui ou non à l'indépendance des
consultations qui n'ont pas de valeur
juridique déclarent les autorités
locales reste que leurs intentions sont
évidentes couper l'herbe sous le pied le
gorbatchev opposé un démenti populaire à
ces affirmations selon lesquelles seules
quelques extrémistes souhaitent
l'indépendance il ya peu de chances que
les dirigeants des deux républiques
obtiennent un résultat comparable au
véritable plébiscite lituanien du mois
de janvier à 60% la population en
estonie 52% lettonie seulement sur le
souss baltes
reste que les indépendantistes espère un
résultat largement favorable d'autant
que la participation semble très faible
dans les régions à majorité russophone
les résultats ne devraient être connues
que dans la nuit ici
michel jobert mirel gorbatchev pourra
tenir face à cette volonté
indépendantistes des trois républiques
baltes
ces cas la question que je me pose je
vivais répondent bien entendu mais il se
susurre envie de vous dire voilà la
vraie démonstration que le droit
international et d'un exercice de
géométrie dans l'espace et que
ce qui est important ici et le quoi on
doit se battre on ne se bat pas là dans
les républiques baltes
on n'aide pas les républiques baltes
elles ont droit à leur liberté depuis
longtemps mais elle ne leur ont pas
qu'est ce qu'elles auront alors pour
répondre à votre question fort
courtoisement je vous dirais que mikhaïl
gorbatchev tout ce qui peut faire de
mieux
il ne peut pas utiliser la force il a
essayé et c'est très difficile
il ya quand même une réprobation
internationale et une réprobation
intérieur il y à la grande république de
russie qui veut sa liberté
le bloc russe russia liberté
par conséquent quel est le destin de
gorbatchev c'est d'essayer de d'adapter
une confédération assez souple pour que
ce soit encore une union de places
soviétique où chacun est une sorte
d'autonomie
le destin de de ce cet immense pays
c'est d'être toutes proportions gardées
toutes proportions renflée une sorte de
yougoslavie comme dirait dargaud savine
ne réussit pas mais enfin elle a tenu
quand même elle à mazamet des peuples
très différent pendant bien des années
et c'est vers cela c'est la meilleure
mauvaise solution comme monsieur
gorbatchev puisse encore avoir
merci messieurs joubert l'actualité en
france 2 attentat non revendiqué ce
matin au centre edf d'orthez des dégâts
importants mais aucune victime
claire sébastien il était environ deux
heures ce matin lorsqu'une violente
explosion a réveillé les habitants de ce
quartier ouest d'orthez en béarn le hall
d'entrée du bâtiment abritant le centre
edf de la ville étaient soufflées par la
déflagration
quelques minutes plus tard une deuxième
explosion détruisent et une dizaine de
voitures de l'administration dans le
garage situé à l'arrière du bâtiment
un commerçant d'orthez qui rentrait
d'une soirée à assister à l'explosion
donc où il ya une très grosse explosion
ou là j'ai eu très très peur et mes
vitres la voiture en tout et être tout
soufflé et ensuite je me suis échappé et
on appris en fait je me suis échappé a
dit m aussitôt être que cette explosion
nous avons pris la voiture nous l'avons
emmené à à 30 m me blue air et là nous
avons regardé il ya eu très très grosse
explosion
cet attentat n'a toujours pas été
revendiqué mais les enjeux utiliser des
bouteilles de gaz semble être selon les
enquêteurs la signature de
l'organisation basque iparretarrak et se
doutant que s'ouvre demain le procès de
sept militants bac louis mermaz n'est
pas venu les mains vides ce matin en
inaugurant le salon de l'agriculture de
paris
le ministre de l'agriculture a annoncé
le lancement d'un plan d'amélioration au
revenu agricole principal souci des
agriculteurs français face à la
politique des 12
un salon qui attend six cent mille
visiteurs et qui compte plus de 1000
exposants
80 ou de mongolie qui devaient être
abattus gambade désormais dans la forêt
du lozère ils viennent d'arriver dans le
parc animalier du gévaudan sous l'oeil
bienveillant de leur bienfaitrice
brigitte bardot reportage fr3 toulouse à
mèze où est donc passé le grand méchant
loup cinq jours de voyage dans des
caisses même prévu pour ça ont presque
transformé le fier animal un agneau
craintifs
en cette ère de gévaudan au cours encore
la légende de la bête
le loup demeure un mythe un mythe qui en
vaut bien un autre brigitte bardot
s'était tout spécialement déplacés pour
assister à l'arrivée de ses protégés 80
ou de mongolie que les hongrois voulait
transformer en fourrure et heureusement
brigitte bardot a été mise au courant et
elle a décidé de sauver celle où est
alors ça il fallait trouver un centre
d'accueil et sainte rose accueille pour
les loups en france et n'a pas tellement
alors donc on a retrouvé quand même les
loups du gévaudan et forcément c'est ici
que les voiries âgés de sept à huit mois
c'est louvard comme les appellent les
spécialistes se remettront vite de leurs
émotions dans ce parc animalier du
gévaudan où ils auront plus de 20
hectares à leur disposition pour couler
des jours heureux et bien nourris
prendre en compte que les 35 que nous
avons au total il en faut entre 2 h et 3
h par semaine et maintenant on triple
l'effectif on doit en valoir 115 nous ce
soir
alors là évidemment il faut il faut 10
10 vaches par semaine mon poids cette
opération a reçu les soutiens multiples
conseil régional du languedoc-roussillon
cee ministère de l'environnement ainsi
que celui de bébé qui a donné ce n'est
qu'au et découverte du même coup une
terre à sa mesure
oui alors je vais vous dire je trouve
que c'est magnifique c'est très très
beau si j'ai déjà ma venue et je
reviendrai sûrement votre campus on a la
paix et c'est un des départements
paraît-il l'émoi peuple est enceinte va
très bien le jour était presque entre
chien et loup quand les rescapés de
hongrie partie en sur un dernier regard
vers leur destin de solitaire plus de
dix mille qui ont participé aujourd'hui
en suède à la célèbre vasaloppet le plus
grand rassemblement annuel de fondeurs
au monde
à l'issue des 89 g km c'est encore une
fois un suédois qui s'est imposé rémi
gaudillat lee
comme chaque année ils étaient près de
10000 comme chaque année il faisait
plutôt froid et comme chaque année ils
sont partis pour 90 km de course à six
heures du matin
la vasaloppet une affaire exclusivement
suédoise à de très rares exceptions près
comme en 1978 tout un étranger français
de surcroît jean paul pierret s'imposait
devant tout un pays pour les meilleurs
de ces échassiers au bonnet à pompon la
victoire s'est jouée en 5 heures et
quelques derniers coups de patte félin
cette année encore c'est un suédois jan
o thomson qui s'est imposée pour fêter
comme il se doit la 67e édition de la
course de ski de fond la plus célèbre du
monde
le prince ghost avait rickson vasa qui
fut il ya quatre siècles un grand
résistant contre l'envahisseur danois
peut être fier de ses descendants
françois mitterrand va s'adresser aux
français dans quelques minutes à 20h
très précisément allocution
radiotélévisée il devrait donner les
axes de la diplomatie pour l'après
guerre
il devrait encourager aussi les français
à relancer la machine économique
c'est la première déclaration directe
aux français sans l'intermédiaire des
journalistes nous nous retrouverons tout
de suite après l'intervention de
françois mitterrand à tout à l'heure
nous avons encore quelques minutes
michel jobert une petite réaction avant
l'intervention de françois mitterrand
est ce que vous estimez que la france a
réussi à faire entendre sa différence
dans la guerre du golfe abba jusqu'ici
non elle a fait entendre son alignement
tout à fait de dire si la france n'a pas
été aligné sur la politique américaine
jane demande sur quoi elle s'est alignée
pas sur la sienne c'est évident alors
tout le calcul qui a été fait c'est que
le prix de cet alignement serait plus de
considération après je crois que ce
raisonnement est faux mais
nous n'avons plus qu'à attendre quelques
mois ou quelques semaines pour voir
comment la position de la france s'ils
allaient cesser les différentes sera
prise en compte par désintérêt qui la
dépasse de beaucoup et par une puissance
qui aujourd'hui est victorieuse voilà on
se retrouve si vous le voulez bien dans
quelques minutes juste après
l'intervention de françois mitterrand
puisqu'elle y il est 19 heures 59 et 54
secondes donc c'est tout de suite
pour nous
je
faisant tu la mettais